Is this a
waterfall, a cult facility, or a love hotel? I
won 11 races in a 72-hour endurance race, but it's a
mountain, and it's better quality than a dormitory. Even in episode 9, I
thought of a technique like six giant spins in a row,
but this
place is Dakini-sama.  Is this the sect of the sect?
Yes, I guess so. Well
then, I'll pass it on to the principal deity. I'm the
vice president of the 3rd branch.
[Music]
You guys should also offer a facility like this to me.
That's it.  You're suppressing your power.
[Music]
Speak. The
teachings of our cult will save you. I
'd like to try the tentacle session that the Principal Buddha mentioned before, but I
can't find the job type anywhere.
I'm worried.  If you think of it as a job, then that's
the job, so if I think about it, then yes,
but the feet and fingers, even the wind and the earth of this world, the
world that is the same as the job, is guided by tentacles all
around.It's true.  These guys